In this problem, we're given a dictionary where the keys are children
and the values are a list of parents,
and given a person, we want to go through the dictionary,
and calculate a list that contains all of that person's ancestors.
So let's go over the plan.
We're going to use recursion.
We're going to find the person that we're searching for in the dictionary.
We're going to add that person's parents, their direct relatives, to the output list,
and then we're going to recurse on the parents to find the ancestors,
adding the result of this recursive call to our output list.
This should be enough to get started,
so let's go right to the editor.
If the person we're searching for is in the genealogy dictionary,
we're going to do what we described previously.
If they're not in the dictionary, we're going to return an empty list
because we don't know any of their ancestors.
So for each parent, we're going to add their ancestors to the result list,
and once we're done, we're going to return the result list. And that's it.